alexa turn on the sprinklers
lori harvey's proud of boyfriend michael
b jordan who just added super bowl
commercial star to his already
impressive resume
alexa
[Music]
the 33 year old actor starred in this ad
for amazon's alexa during sunday's big
game
and lori shared these videos to her
insta stories of them watching his big
game debut
she even captured michael's hilarious
reaction after the commercial
ended lori went on to highlight how the
black panther stars ad
racked up some serious youtube views
before its airing during the super bowl
50 million of them as of monday that
number has climbed to over
75 million read my audiobook
i was in his hands i was being changed
michael and lori's adorable display
follows another important social media
moment for the couple
i wanted to be as authentic as i could
in january they put an end to romantic
speculation
and made their relationship instagram
official
the couple shared these romantic photos
tagging each other
in the loving pics taken by leo valsey
with lori captioning her post with a
heart emoji
a little anxious i'm excited a source
told e.t at the time that michael and
lori have been dating for months
adding that michael has been ready for a
serious relationship for a while
and they were friends for years before
they got together in 2020.
the pair has even met each other's
families including laurie's famous dad
steve harvey okay just men are very
simple
are they men are very simple the family
feud host recently had some
fun commenting on their relationship
during an episode of the steve harvey
morning show
the comedian said quote i like this one
and jokingly
added i still got my eye on him he's
sexy
and lucky lori her boyfriend is also the
reigning sexiest man alive
jordan hilariously announced the new
title on jimmy kimmel live
in november but i think even maybe more
rewarding for you
is look michael jordan is a tiny little
sexy person
and you're the big sexy person
i'll take that difference i'm not gonna
have too many of those over mj so i'm
gonna take that one